will we see gold dip below a thousand
dollars that's the one big question the
second big question is what does it mean
for the guys that pull this stuff out of
the ground yeah well ABN amro says we
could they're forecasting a price of
eleven hundred dollars by the end of
this year 800 by the end of next year
now when he says that they don't they
allocate capital a thousand bucks what
he's really saying in layman's speech is
he's ready to build a mind as long as
the price of gold is above a thousand
bucks so that's his business model we
actually looked at 19 different gold
companies 12 of the 19 at the current
oil the current gold price are actually
profitable that means seven of them
aren't their production cost is higher
than what they're able to sell the gold
at now if the price of gold falls by
another 50 bucks that number of seven
non-profitable gold producers actually
increases by 2 29 so there's an awful
lot of unprofitable gold production out
there in fact we talked to one analysts
who said about a third of all the gold
being produced right now in the world is
being produced at a loss which is a
pretty staggering concept and what
you're getting in the market as one
analyst put it is a two-tier situation
where you've got the likes of Wrangell
which have been allocating at a thousand
dollars and are still sitting pretty
because they're making money as they
take gold out of the ground and you've
got if you will the losers who in the
run up to nineteen hundred dollars an
ounce started allocating at fifteen
hundred dollars start building mines
assuming that the price of gold was
going to remain above 1500 and they're
right now obviously in a world of hurt
because they're not making money right
now as they take the gold out of the
ground and if i'm looking at share
prices Ryan is this the trend that
continues because rankles been heard
over the last couple of months on the
year though it's really held up yeah I
mean you know speaking of randgold I
think one interesting thing to do is to
take those two tiers and look how they
compare so randgold the price of its
shares has been falling but if you
compare it to sort of a if you will
second-tier company a company that is
producing right now at a loss like
harmony minor which is harmony mining
which is not in a very harmonious
situation right now as South Africa's
third-largest producer because their
break-even cost is 1250 bucks an ounce
what you'll see is they're falling in a
much greater rate so that beckons the
question of well is it time for MA
because what we do know is that the gold
industry with the exception of one
quarter last year has not done an
extraordinarily good job at cutting
costs the break-even cost for the
industry has remained for the last
couple years if it's trip out that one
quarter about a thousand bucks so MA
well you know I was asking the CEO of
Wrangell about that he said the thing is
what you get first you're going to have
to wait a little while is is gold
producers effectively selling off the
assets that they don't want this is
going to have to continue for some time
before they start to really feel the
stress before they put themselves if you
will up for sale and he said by the way
he's a little bit concerned about taking
a short-term view in an M&A perspective
you heard him their say because there is
a little bit of a correction that's
necessary because there's just too much
be gold being produced right now